there's more than two that's when people
say both I think they're missing the
mark because there are many many
political parties we talked about this
before the show you said Congress Thomas
you were telling me yeah it's like set
up for two party literally built with
the fact that there's an aisle forces
you into two halves tell me more about
this I said there's coat rooms there's a
cloak room there are two cloak rooms
there aren't three I've thought about
this because I feel like a trans
partisan someday I don't know which
cloak room to go into but because
there's only two and they shoehorn you
know there's probably six or seven kinds
of parties that aren't named in our
country right now but then you
shoehorned them into two parties every
Committee hearing room has two back
rooms you know you hear about backroom
deals okay they literally call them back
rooms and there are exactly two back
rooms with every Committee hearing room
they even have a smoking section right
yes smoking section yeah like there's a
Democrat smoking section a republican
smoking section in the cloak rooms
there's a smoking section oh okay wow
but it's built into the it's built into
the architecture it would be really hard
and it's built into the rules like every
committee they say well we're going to
portion the committee based on the
majority and minority party the fact
that there's a a majority leader and a
minority leader and it should probably
cap it like we're going to set like each
Party 10 parties and you want 20
community members that means there can
be two from each party and then that'll
incentivize people to go to other
parties that don't have that many people
yet so they have a better chance of
getting on a committee I'm sure there's
a better way to do it I am absolutely
certain
well then what it what can we do
I I'll let me just elaborate a little
bit I mean you mentioned last time you
were here there's like what you what do
you say 10 Democrats on one side 10
Republicans and there's some random guy
rating going like this bill says this
Democrats Republicans the Democrats get
it bang like that happens yes oh yeah
that just says every day Congress is is
is is is is is is broken it's theater
theater so what do we do to fix that
that well we've asked for recorded votes
all year um so for this this past year
in 2021 I believe there's been over 490
bills that we've requested recorded
votes that's that hasn't happened in a
very long time in Congress this this is
amazing and this is what inspires me and
gives me hope going forward you're
looking for some kind of hope
Marjorie Taylor green gives me hope like
on March 27 2020 I was the only person
asking for a recorded vote on the
biggest spending bill in history it was
verboten to do that it was not
acceptable and then Marjorie came and
just made it the normal course that yeah
we're going to vote on everything she
didn't have committees so she sat on the
floor there were you know if there were
going to be three people in there there
was going to be one more and it was
Marjorie that's right and she just
started asking for recorded votes but
there are a dozen other people who will
take turns watching the floor and asking
for when you went in demanded that
everybody come in and vote how long did
it take when you went in and when they
all got there
but real real quick
you you've you've set up a system now
where among the real people in Congress
we have a schedule you make sure there's
someone there to demand we take turns
every single week we're there in session
we sign up for it and we I mean we sit
on the floor sometimes we're texting
each other no one's down there or I have
a meeting I can't go and we work our way
around and we make sure here's what's
disturbing it's amazing it is amazing
and it's inspiring because it used to be
me and I'm like I gotta go to the
bathroom and I'm pretty sure and then I
ended up being in that position and oh
it's miserable well then they vote when
you walk out of the room yeah yeah oh my
God yes they do oh my gosh they
literally wait for you to leave that may
have been why on March 27th the
president called me
while the took you out of the road yeah
to get me out of the room I'm not sure
if they had timed it that well but I I
stayed unless calls go to voicemail let
me let me just
but but let me just say so that's
inspiring what that we've got shifts and
stuff but that's what your party
leadership supposed to do
the the minority leader and the minority
whip they've got a dozen staff members
on the floor that know exactly what's
going to happen next they're working on
the script with Nancy Pelosi they know
which bills are coming and they should
be asking for the votes so let me tell
you a funny story
um motion to adjourn you know I love
motion to adjourn motion to adjourn is
is something any member of Congress can
step up and make a motion to adjourn
that that it calls for everyone to have
to vote to end Congress for the day and
I believe oftentimes Congress is so out
of control I love to make a motion to
adjourn well recently I came down to the
house floor and I was going to make a
motion to adjourn and
um Nancy Pelosi found out because I told
one of the one of the floor staffers
that I was going to do it
so she came out and she opened the the
day you know she started the whole day
and it's and she looked at me directly
and she was talking faster than normally
until she was irritated and then you
know what she did she said the house
will be in recess
and she didn't let anyone do their
one-minute speeches and there were
several members that were really mad at
me because they didn't get to do their
one-minute speeches because they knew it
was because I was going to do a motion
to adjourn wow but they do they they
talk I want to I want to let you know
that uh after the first time you came on
I had people messaging me friends and
family saying when I heard that Congress
doesn't actually go and vote and
Marjorie said she started demanding it
and forcing them to do their jobs people
were like that was the moment I realized
she was great and she was amazing and I
loved her I didn't I didn't know I mean
you come here and tell me that uh the
stuff about how they
they're basically just not doing their
jobs you tell us this stuff you talk
about how they'll they'll wait for you
to leave the room before voting
I don't think regular people realize how
broken the whole system really is or or
more specifically you say they don't
enforce the masking until in areas where
there's no cameras it's all for show I
think when you tell people that
congress's approval rating is so far in
the gutter [ __ ] that they're willing to
believe it and then when you mention oh
yeah and we're rotating shifts to make
sure they all have to do their jobs I'm
sure people started laughing their asses
off when they heard that well it let's
not say who the member is can we agree
if I tell this story yes okay so
Marjorie had asked for a recorded vote
and and people were going to miss some
fundraisers and they were really mad and
this was uh and I saw people one at a
time coming up to Marjorie and just
saying stuff to her and so I'm not nice
things so I went and sat next to her and
and one of our colleagues sat next to
her as well Scott Perry great guy great
guy thinking that they wouldn't have the
audacity to come up and and yell at a
woman for actually just doing her job
well an individual did and I'm not going
to name him and and he started
mansplaining to Marjorie he literally
said it ain't over me he said I know
you're trying really hard to do this job
and I know you care a lot but you need
to be thoughtful about this
and after about 60 seconds that I
couldn't take it anymore and I said you
know what
if your constituents could see you if
they could hear you right now they would
be so upset with you you got to say who
it is no no no and then he turned
because we got to be friends so he
turned his ire to me
and said you you worry about your own
District I know what my constituents
want and I'll take care of my votes and
you take care of yours and you mind your
own business and I said you know what if
you're if you're that certain that your
constituents are happy with what you're
saying go down to the microphone say it
in front of the camera let them hear it
I'm still shocked that it's not live
streamed all that action with little
Mike lapels so that we can just watch
you guys it's not like your puppets but
I mean what a reality I would oh I'd
give anything for a reality show but I
want to tell you something Thomas Massey
was the first person to stand up for me
and that was the first time it happened
the rest of the time I had been berated
and taking so much anger and horrible
things from other Republicans that were
mad at me for for asking for recorded
votes because they were going to be on
record they're cowards but Thomas Massey
stood up for you and you want to know
why he talked he's talked about he he
went and was forcing everyone to come
back to Washington when on the biggest
spending biggest spending bill in this
pandemic that in our nation's history
and he was saying our constitution is
still intact this is so important we
have to vote on this and you wouldn't
have believed what he had to go through
I mean
I love president Trump but he he had to
deal with the phone calls and the tweets
and everyone mad and angry at him and
then he had his colleagues mad and angry
at him and everyone called him non-stop
trying to talk him out of it and he
still stood firm and he stood firm and
he made sure our constitution stayed
intact and this is such an incredible
story I I truly think it's an important
part of our history that Thomas Massey
did that during this uh covid-19 bio
weapon I'll say that I think it's that
and we have to prove it but but during
this what was happening to our country
we had one member of Congress willing to
make sure that our constitution stood in
this in this historic time I'll be
honest I think I I was even critical I
think at the time my reaction was like
now is not the time for grandstanding
when we're being shut down and we're in
desperate need of Aid and relief and but
I'll make mistakes I think you know now
I look back at the mass spending and the
disaster that it's been by the way
there's they roll out contingency
government plans when things stop
working when the three branches quit
functioning they've got a contingency
plan and it is not pretty directive 51
right no no no no uh not area 51. no no
no no Presidential Directive 51 not
familiar with that but that was uh it's
been updated but uh George W Bush signed
into uh uh an executive order called
National Security Presidential Directive
51 which unilaterally grants the
Executive Branch the right in any
disaster to reform the government under
one branch under the executive branch
where they would have a national
continuity coordinator who would control
the other branches effectively and their
justification is a mass casualty event
anywhere in the world a financial
disaster anywhere in the world it's been
updated since then and expanded but it's
never been tested because it's an
executive decree so we'd see we'll see
how that could ever play out if it could
I want to mention something you just uh
said that you believe that covet is a
bio weapon it's interesting because
according to Dr Francis Boyle who
drafted the American implementation of
the national or I'm sorry of the
International bioweapons Convention any
disease or virus created through gain of
function research is a de facto bio
weapon it doesn't have to have been made
with the intent necessarily being a bio
weapon the reason this is so easy to get
fuzzy on and why they can deny that it
is one is because they can argue well
yes we used gain of function research
to create this virus but we were only
making it because if someone else made
the same virus we would want to have it
first so we could know how to cure it
but that's like saying well my gun isn't
a weapon because the reason I have it is
just to study it take it apart clean it
I don't plan on using it well whether
you plan on using it or not it is still
a weapon and if these were if this was
created through gain a function research
it's a biological weapon whether they
claim that was the purpose or not and
that is again according to the man who
literally authored the legislation on
what a biological weapon is I agree my
analogy extending on that is they were
playing with matches in the house caught
on fire yes and they said well we were
playing with matches so we would know
how to put a house exactly but guess
what they ran they didn't they did not
try to put the house out they ran away
and and denied they were playing with
matches yeah yeah exactly well and then
denied that they were matches in the
first place a bat came in and lit this
place on fire well look look when you
when you get Jon Stewart coming out and
making those accusations on Stephen
Colbert the show this is not a fringe
idea this is something the American
people believe thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel Monday
through Friday at 8pm now don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this Channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time